c'est prochainement que le prince harry
et meghan markle vont donner naissance à
leur deuxième enfant événement people en
france mais un véritable chamboulement
nationale en angleterre la mise en place
d'un véritable business
car à chaque naissance d'un bébé royal
les anglais dépensent des sommes folles
pour acheter des produits dérivés par
exemple mais aussi l'un des nombreux
paris d'argent autour des noms du bébé
il y a déjà des prénoms qui sortent du
lot première position arthur des paris
qui sont devenus un business très
important et qui rapporte des millions
d'euros aussi des bookmakers
et cette naissance ne sera pas seulement
un événement pour les européens puisque
le frère ou la soeur du petit archi
devrait voir le jour à los angeles ville
où habitent désormais harry et mégane
il pourrait donc bénéficier d'une double
nationalité à leur nouveau bébé pour
mégane et harry comprenez vous
l'engouement médiatique alors moi par
exemple mais moi je mets voyons alors je
vous pose la question parce que moi tout
le monde
ils sont tous comme des fous à chaque
fois qu'ils aient un boyals béni mais
moi mais je me suis souvent car le cul
vraiment mais je m'en serais je suis
totalement pourquoi cet engouement
pourquoi fabien lecoeuvre pourquoi
bernard montiel
le spécialiste a regardé il faut rêver
et le pudding déjà ils font rêver en
plus ces symboles de l'opposition après
cet ancien monde avec sonia palato plein
d'articles ya plein de bookmakers ont
parlé du prénom du bébé
les prénoms les plus parier c'est
alexandra hi fi ou diana donc en hommage
à la maman d'harry et ils vont prendre
la parole publiquement pour tout dire
sur ce futur accouchement et ce futur
bébé
ce sera la télévision américaine le 7
mars prochain et buckingham et flipper
de cette interview parce qu'isabelle qui
balance encore sur le palace à l'étude
et quelle naïveté idées naïves et l'ail
et enfin se foutent de nous mais ghanéen
qui se fout de nous ils disent on rompt
avec la famille royale
et puis sont tous leur beurre sur la fin
mais qui s'emmerdent attaquer tous les
journaux anglais pour gagner plus de ils
ont bien donné un million de largeur du
business du beurre mais c'est normal
c'est honteux
mais la question c'est dire moi je m'en
fous complètement
mais je comprends pas pourquoi les gens
sienne moi je dois me je mens car les
faits tels qu'ils ont aujourd'hui à
oprah winfrey donc l'interview exclusive
ses illusions billion de dollars ou bien
d'accord doivent former des ventes s'est
quand même il ya une cohésion collective
qu'on doit se poser c'est quoi leur
métier ces people ils ont rompu
on se marie on fait on fait des enfants
alors mr garde quand même leur métier
non mais c'est quand même la céramiste à
dire que se marier faire des enfants et
plus ample et moi je vous dis avril et
une maman sera toujours une bague ont
bien sûr mais c'est donc mais il faut
dire les choses pas passez un papa une
maman c'est une maman on courait que
c'est à dire c'est déjà un coup d'eau
qui sont paradoxe en permanence c'est à
dire qui fuit un peu les photographes
mais avec des parapluies mais en même
temps ils vendent leur photo à la presse
la clé de la saint valentin il diffuse
l'annoncent assura du produit prochain
c'est à des trucs c'est un métier non
mais c'est un métier et je rejoins
gilles verdez là dessus alors ils
régalien d'amis à moi
ramzy qui me dit et autour de la table
c'est quoi leur métier
[Rires]
non mais le royal baby c'est une aubaine
pour le business vous savez qu'on est à
rapporter la naissance du premier fils
de kate et william
combien 156 millions ou la rente
ben ouais pandémie alors comment
s'appelle n'est pas en baisse alors et
presse à seyssins bientôt s'y connaît en
argent c'est toujours quand on ne râle
mois consécutif
voilà ça bouge là où il a tort c'est que
la famille royale s'est passé pas une
marque déposée c'est à dire que tout le
monde a droit de fabriquer quelque chose
pour faire de l'argent mais non pardon
de capture sera portée c'est un sac à
vomi non comme kate était très malade
ils ont fait des sacs à vomi à 3,5 par
an jure et dessus il y avait des filles
du couple ouvre la séance a cédé info
voilà géraldine maillet heureusement que
vous êtes là voilà et oui alors non mais
vous vraiment les gens vous regardent
mais des gens souvent les gens souffrent
avec ce tee shirt oui gilles à tort ils
ont fait un choix dans l'effort et la
loire le palais et aujourd'hui ils ont
des frais à cause de ce départ ils ont
plein de gardes du corps ils sont donc
ils doivent rentrer de l'argent massif
ils payent de leur poche des paparazzi
encore
la nouvelle de la famille royale ou quoi
ils ont des frais et enfin le canada ils
n'ont même pas demandé de titres royaux
pour le bébé ont voulu s'émanciper et
d'ailleurs la jeune emma était un
scandale a été prévenu au dernier moment
juste avant l'annoncé s'introduire
bearzot parce que moi j'ai entendu
agadir un papa papa tient meeting mamie
non mais ils vous remercient une grand
mère aimait comme une nuit très vite le
ou non mais très vite j'ai eu besoin
d'argent parce que en fait ils ont les
trois millions de livres que leur papa
mais son blindé sodas sont vendus à
netflix spotify netflix pourtant ce
n'aurait pour seul à 50 millions de
dollars le contrat sens à l'aise
ensemble ils sont beaux et 30 millions
avec spotify il sourit oui mais si le
feb est né en californie ce sera un
drame avec la famille royale et ça c'est
mes béquilles de non retour
on va écouter
franchement je vous dire je m'en foutais
bas vous m'avez intéressés
vous aura dit non mais je vous le dis
bravo bravo bravo